for example let's have a look at this
guy right what you're doing is you're
adding up a series of rectangles right
adding up a series of rectangles now we
developed in series and sequences
language to talk about when you're
adding a bunch of things together that
are in order okay
we designed this notation here right
Sigma remember why we chose the Greek
letter Sigma it's s for some right
you're adding up a bunch of things okay
now the particular things that we're
adding up ah well I've got one two three
four rectangles okay so for instance I
could say looked from one to four okay
what am I going to add up well each one
is a rectangle how do you work out the
area of a rectangle yeah it's gonna be
um Bay base times height
well high times we know however you want
you safe okay so when you look at this
guy
right this is a particular function
what's the height of each one of these
rectangles going to be for example how
do I work out the height of this
rectangle
I know it's trivial but how do I
actually went to that like I know it's
zero that's the first one but how do I
read it that numbers you were at come
from very good it came from this y
coordinate that's right okay from and
then this one this next one over well
the height of this rectangle comes from
the y coordinate there and then the next
one over comes from the Y coiler there
and there and so on does that make sense
so what I'm adding up is the y
coordinate y and what am i multiplying
by that height
it's uh it's one of these wits here do
you agree with that so there's the whole
width there I multiply by two but then I
divide by I divide by four in this case
because each one of them is 1/2 1/2 1/2
1/2 that's what gives me - ok ok
I'm pushing this just a little bit more
okay because what I want is for this
wife in well there's actually several
different wise ok so then is like the
first one and then the second one that
way and so on ok so I'm going to
designate this wine
ok I've used K yeah me you could use n
if you want or already letters that you
like it's just counting that's the
important thing
ok how about this one what's happening
here what is different ok I'm still I'm
still adding up stuff right but the
first difference that you notice
yeah I'm adding up eight objects rather
than adding up four of them ok with that
so I'm gonna go from one to eight ok
still adding up the same like the
heights I still get them in the same way
I still look at the y-coordinate but the
the width of each section has changed
right you see that the width is still
two divided by something but I'm
dividing by more of them right so you
can see I'm getting more sections right
more of these rectangles but they're
getting thinner right first there are
half in width and then they are quarter
in width so now from here from these
particular examples let's generalize ok
survey generalizing I want to think
about this not just if I had four
sections or eight sections and not just
with this particular like y equals x
square here's the way I'm going to write
it off I'm going to say the area because
that's the problem I'm trying to solve
it's approximately equal to okay
now I'm adding up a bunch of things and
how many of these little slices
rectangles do you want
I don't know how many other ones so I'm
just gonna call that one in okay you can
choose your M here I chose four here I
chose eight you would choose one to a
desired accuracy like maybe eight
hundred or eight million depending on
how big your area was what am i adding
up I'm going to be adding up mountain
here who needs my function notation okay
instead of just saying why I'm gonna say
if all of the x value that I have to put
in okay so I guess what would correspond
to Y of K would be X of K like that's
the actual number like a quarter a half
sorry a half one one and a half - okay
so that's the number I'm gonna plug into
the function okay so I'll pull that X so
I'm adding up a whole bunch of things
this represents the height of each
rectangle what
now in each of these cases I just picked
two as my arbitrary endpoint okay but
maybe I want to end somewhere else okay
so the place that I would end would be
the K value of x like the last one maybe
it would be the eighth value of x or the
fourth value of x all of a millionth
value of x okay in other words it's
gonna be X okay but that's not that's
that's the whole section right I want
the width of every individual rectangle
right so how wide is each rectangle I
have to divide by however many number of
rectangles I've chosen to divide by so
let's let's end like that's whatever
number I like okay so let's just pause
for a second okay what what does this
thing mean because this is you know it's
death by notation here okay what we are
doing doing is we are summing a series
of areas right we are summing
sorry that's alright a height times a
width okay
in other words what we have something is
a bunch of rectangles that's what height
on Smith represents okay now his way of
Riemann and he's um is pursue to not
just say approximately equal to I can do
better than that right if I could take
this kind of thing right four rectangles
epic tangled I said numbers like 800 or
a million they all still going to be
approximately but very close but they be
approximately with normal tools that's
where I have to stop but we have
mathematical tools a disposable we don't
have to stop at eight or 800 or a
million we can go to infinity if we want
right instead of this kind of scenario
we're going to have a scenario like this
yes sir glad you lost we're gonna get to
that okay